a major thing I've discussed recently is
deck consistency and I've been surprised
by how much feedback I've gotten in
multiple Dimensions I've had people
telling me I'm B merching the spirit of
a Singleton format but I've also had a
lot of people who were interested and
genuinely curious about how to make a
deck consistent so I figured for this
video I can spend 10 minutes yelling at
that first group of people about how
wrong they are all right listen here you
bozos no those people are entailed to
the deck building preferences and I wish
them well I actually want to give a more
detailed look at deck consistency as a
subject with an emphasis on the how
what's the best way to turn a floppy
pile of Jank into a well-oiled machine
to get there I want to start by
clarifying my terms I throw around the
phrase consistent deck a lot and one
interpretation of a consistent deck is
one that does the same thing every game
I think that this is a very incomplete
definition for what I'm talking about
and the definition I'm going to use
instead is that a consistent deck is one
that consistently does something and
whose things it does don't vary all that
much in power level this often means
decks with multiple Avenues of play
whose construction is good enough that
the different options all feel valuable
the three decks I mentioned in my last
video my $25 ratos deck My Maria deck
and my glissa deck all basically do
variations on a theme with glissa the
deck might take different opening plays
depending on the game but at the end of
the day the general game plan will be
ramp play big stuff and gain board
dominance similarly with my Maria deck
the deck is always looking to play a
bunch of equipments and swing big in the
mid game but that can take a bunch of
different shapes if you want to learn
more about the Maria deck I recently
posted a 10-minute Deck Tech over on my
patreon that covers the process of how I
built it a breakdown of the list and
some takeaways I had from the deck
building process I've mentioned a
handful of reasons I like consistent
decks in the past and I'll give a brief
rehash here from a table politics
standpoint people will remember the most
powerful moments of your deck your
spooky pop off win that you can only
pull off 10% of the time will be
remembered alongside a more consistent
deck quite solid game plan it pulls off
75% of the time and this will make your
deck seem disproportionately scary even
if table memory isn't a concern from a
fun standpoint I like to have a deck be
doing something every game this is
doubly true when I'm playing with new
people where my deck failing to get off
the ground will look an awful lot like I
just built a bad deck rather than being
seen as the unfortunate sequence of
draws it truly was to be clear this is
absolutely an ego thing but fortunately
for me for the moment we all have human
brains that do silly human brain things
so I know a decent proportion of you
sharing my vanity at table now that I've
got the what and the why out of the way
let's talk how for starters I think one
of the easier forms of consistency to
nail is what I like to call roll out
consistency this type of consistency
basically asks the question do I do what
I want to do on the first several turns
of the game game that what can vary deck
to deck and obviously you won't play a
turn one soul ring every game but you
can check to make sure your deck is
generally doing at least something that
feels good the best way of doing this is
solo play testing a deck a whole bunch
and I generally play test my decks quite
a lot before spending any money on them
however this can be a timec consuming
process and one way of reducing this
time is having a baseline of
probabilistic sense for the cards in
your deck so you're at least in the
general ballpark with things and anybody
who plays a lot of card games will have
this intuitively hammered in to an
extent but just for fun I'm going to
show you exactly what I mean here let's
say I want to look at how often I get a
particular type of card by a particular
turn using the example of a goreclaw
deck I've been building the deck always
wants to play the commander by turn
three and this means that it needs to
get a piece of ramp by turn two every
game disregarding Mulligans lands and
other factors the probability of this
happening is modeled by this function
where X is the number of ramp spells in
my deck and it can be used to graph out
How likely it is to achieve this goal
based on that number as we can see on
the graph if I have 10 ramp spells in
the deck there's a 63% chance of having
one on turn two if there's 15 in a deck
I have a 79% chance if there's 20 I have
an 88% chance and so on all right now
let's say instead I really want to see
ramp in the opening hand and we happily
Mulligan to get there if I decide to run
15 ramp spells then for a given seven
card hand there's a 69.6% chance of
having at least one ramp spell and this
graph lays out the probability based on
the number of hands drawn for one hand
drawn it's
69.6% for two hands it's 90.8% for three
hands it's
97.2% and so on a simple Benchmark you
can reference is that you need a 10 of a
card in a deck to have it show up in a
given hand more than half the time you
could also do this sort of modeling for
a combo deck for this hypothetical
persist combo deck running no tutors and
no partial pieces in order to have a
better than half chance of drawing one
of each piece to have the combo you need
to draw roughly half the deck and
there's about a 1 in 400 chance of
drawing it in the opening hand another
possible calculation would be modeling
land drops given a certain land count by
showing you this kind of modeling I'm
certainly not trying to say that you
should go out and get a degree in math
before building a deck I almost never
run this sort of calculation while deck
building
what I am trying to say though is that
it's good to have a rough idea of the
actual numbers of the situation I think
a lot of people tend to underestimate
how many cards 100 actually is and that
tends to result in people putting in
less cards with a particular effect than
would be ideal this also then has other
effects on the card quality you might
build out the core of a deck and then go
wow I've got so many slots left I could
put all sorts of stuff in here I've been
there and let me tell you those decks
end up turning out way worse than decks
where I'm sweating and dying trying to
fit everything in when slots are
plentiful filler that weakens the deck
as a whole will work its way in cards
where you go oh this seems decent in a
couple n situations or oh yeah this card
has slight synergies with a couple other
elements of the deck these cards are
probably there in place of other better
suited cards a good first step toward
reducing this sort of filler is to
categorize your deck and think about the
category
different decks will use different
systems but for supporting categories I
usually have are ramp draw removal and
protection with those last two
categories sometimes combined for decks
whose interaction mainly consists of
counter spells separating these out and
making sure you have enough of each is a
good first step of making sure that
you're spending slots on things that
will actually make your deck better
rather than throwing in some random pet
enchantments within the categories there
might be a question of whether a card
truly belongs there for for example is
gilded Lotus ramp if you're accelerating
to 10 or more Mana to play a lot of big
threats yes it is if you're running
ramps so that you can hit a six Mana
Commander consistently no it's not ramp
for draw you should consider the
difference between conditional draw
general purpose draw and filtering since
if your deck relies too heavily on
conditional draw you'll have games where
you get behind and then stay behind once
you've figured out your categories and
considered what sorts of cards should
make up a given category the next
question might be how much of each to
run and this will vary deck to deck
things like draw and ramp can be tested
via play testing but reactive elements
will be trickier to figure out for
removal I'd recommend starting between 8
and 14 and adjust from there keeping in
mind that slower decks and lower
velocity decks will usually want more
removal than faster decks and higher
velocity decks will protection is the
most variable of all I run zero in a
couple Scrappy Decks that don't give a
about anything and 12 in the Maria
deck whose supporting categories are
currently on screen where my commander
Staying Alive a extra turn might mean a
dead opponent and a bunch of value how
much protection is correct for your deck
will depend on how much it cares about
its commander and other key cards
surviving and if you care about that a
lot I'd like to remind you that if
you're only running the Two Boots your
odds of drawing protection in your first
five draws of the game
are a hair under
23% that's not great a helpful side
effect of categorizing is that it will
will naturally leave some cards in
undeniably naked view if a card doesn't
fit into one of your key categories you
should be asking yourself what its
purpose is and the answer should be
simple and straightforward if the answer
involves scratching your head and
vaguely gesturing at a couple other
cards that's a card that deserves a more
robust
evaluation in my mind the optimal state
of a deck list is one whose components
exist in comfortable tension in your
mind were there are constantly questions
on the back of your mind like hm should
I swap out a ramp spell and a finisher
slot for two more draw spells the answer
to that can be no but asking that kind
of question in the first place will
improve your decks and make you better
at deck building a final type of
consistency I want to talk about is one
that's complex enough that I might make
a full video about it at some point and
that is situational consistency by this
phrase I made up on the spot I mean a
deck that plays relatively smoothly in a
number of different situations you could
also call this being reactive Andor
being resilient depending on context
this will generally mean devoting deck
space to specific types of suppressive
or protective cards and the best way to
allow a deck to have easy access to
situational cards without destroying the
deck's General consistency is
tutors this could mean running a bunch
of the black Classics but those tend to
be expensive either MoneyWise or Mana
wise so for a deck looking to run a
bunch of tutors a natural place to end
up is often what's called a toolbox deck
this refers to a deck with a number of
conditional tutors that can each grab
cards useful in several different
situations a couple quintessential
toolbox cards are birthing pod and Yan
The Wanderer Bard which work well in
decks with a lot of card diversity at
each Mana cost there are some really
powerful toolbox decks out there as
higher powers are where being able to
consistently find Tech pieces and
answers really shines for a couple
examples of toolbox Decks at a lower
power I can talk about my shirom slide
deck and my friend Mr hans's vrock deck
in shirom Slide the primary objective of
the toolbox is grabbing AST slide but
there are a ton of other options
embedded into this enchantment artifact
and wizard-based tutoring framework
board wipes recurent spells draw spells
life gain and so forth this means that
the deck can flow nicely once it gets
into the mid game even though the
interesting Mana base can often lead to
slow early games in the vrock deck
equipments are the primary card type
that the tutor base is oriented around
with the equipment base containing value
protection defense graveyard hate and
sunforger with sunforger the deck can
hit a ton of different different cards
including a convoluted infinite combo
which results in a mutate deck that's a
little strange but very fun and
flexible as an end note to this section
I should probably mention I know that a
lot of people dislike tutors and I think
a lot of that dislike comes down to a
particular type of usage somebody tutors
up a power card or a couple combo pieces
and then explodes the table this might
feel Bland to play against but I want to
pose a question is it more interesting
when a deck draws into that explosive
win out of pure luck it'll happen less
often without tutors sure but having the
question of whether you'll lose to a
two-card infinite combo be up to a roll
of the dice rather than it being tutored
doesn't really seem better in any
meaningful sense if anything it makes it
more difficult to run counterplay for
that sort of deck a stack piece you
throw in will sit unutilized the 85% of
the time that they're doing something
else my advice is this if you don't like
a particular type of Windon or a
particular power level that's fine and
there's probably a different table out
there that you'll like
better all right that's this video
coming to an end I have two things to
mention here one I made a website and
put a couple probability calculators up
on it because I was bored and wanted an
excuse to practice my JavaScript so you
can visit there if you want to know the
probability of drawing a card of a given
type by a given turn or the average turn
you'll miss a land drop with a given
land count ooh turn seven that's pretty
cool secondly I feel I should reiterate
as with my last video this is a style of
building that you can engage in but not
every deck will be well served by being
transparent or maximizing consistency
just leaving that out there anyway
here's a preview of the Maria Deck Tech
I recently posted to my
patreon starting with ramp this deck is
a good example of how stopping to think
about what you're actually trying to
accomplish with your ramp is a great
step I'm not trying to cast my commander
on turn two it does nothing without
artifacts in play I also don't have many
big cards to ramp to and my commander
gives me enough Mana to get there even
when I do have one
so what do I need ramp for two things
one holding up interaction and two
replaying my commander and a bunch of
equip costs if I do run into problems
fortunately both of these use cases are
satisfied by a very particular type of
card and one that has to be an equipment
on top of all of it treasure generators
like gold Vin pick a difficulty for
faster decks is having Mana to hold up
interaction since if you have a two Mana
spell for the purposes of Mana
efficiency keeping it up at all times is
effectively like getting two of your
lands destroyed this kind of sucks and
is solved beautifully by Treasures whose
one-time use means that they're never
wasted